because you're now directing all of deep
learning at deepmind you get to interact
with a lot of projects a lot of
brilliant researchers
um
how much variability is created by the
humans in all of this yeah i mean you i
do believe humans matter a lot at the
very least at the
you know time scale of years
on when things are happening and what's
the sequencing of it right so you get to
interact with
people that i mean you mentioned this um
some people really
want some idea to work and they'll
persist um and then some other people
might be more practical like i don't
care
what idea works i care about you know
cracking protein folding yes um and
these at least these two kind of seem
opposite sides we need both and we've
clearly had both
um historically and that made certain
things happen earlier or later so
definitely humans involved in all of
this endeavor have had
i would say years of change or of
ordering how how things have happened
which breakthroughs came before which
other breakthroughs and so on so
certainly that does happen and so
one other maybe one other axis of
distinction is what i called and this is
most commonly used in reinforcement
learning is the exploration exploitation
trade-off as well it's not exactly what
i meant although quite related so
when you
start
trying to help others right like you
you're you're you know you're you become
a bit more of a mentor to a large group
of people be a project or the deep
learning team or something um or even in
the community when you interact with
people in conferences and so on
um you're identifying
quickly right um so my some things that
are explorative or exploitative and
it's tempting to try to guide people
obviously i mean that's what makes like
our experience we bring it and we try to
shape things um sometimes wrongly and
there's many times that i've been wrong
in the past that's great
but
it would be wrong to
dismiss any sort of
of the research styles that i'm
observing um and i often get asked well
you're in industry right so we do have
access to large compute scale and so on
so there's certain kinds of research i
almost feel like we need to do
responsibly and so on but it is kind of
we have the particle accelerator here so
to speak in physics so we need to use it
we need to answer the questions that we
should be answering right now for the
scientific progress but then at the same
time i look at many advances including
attention which was discovered
in montreal initially because of lack of
compute right so we were working on
sequence to sequence um with with my
friends over at google brain at the time
and we were using i think eight gpus
which was somehow a lot at the time and
then i think montreal was a bit more
limited in the scale but then they
discovered this content-based attention
concept that then has obviously
triggered things like transformer not
everything obviously starts transformer
there's there's always a history that is
is important to recognize because then
you can make sure that then those who
might feel now well we don't have so
much compute
you need to then help them
optimize
that the kind of research that might
actually produce amazing change perhaps
it's not
as short term as some of these
advancements or perhaps it's a different
time scale but um the people and the
diversity of the field is quite critical
to me to that we maintain it and at
times especially mixed a bit with hype
or other things it's it's a bit tricky
to be observing um maybe too much of the
same thinking across the board um but
the humans definitely are critical and i
can think of yeah quite a few personal
examples where also
someone told me something that had a
huge you know huge effect on on to some
idea and then that's why i'm saying at
least at the temp in terms of years
probably some things do happen yes
yeah and it's also fascinating how
constraints somehow are essential for
innovation
um
and the other thing you mentioned about
engineering i have a sneaking suspicion
maybe i
over
you know my my love is with engineering
so
i have a sneaking suspicion that all the
genius
a large percentage of the genius is in
the tiny details of engineering
so like i think
we like to think our genius our the
genius is in the big ideas
there's i have a sneaking suspicion that
like because i've seen the genius of
details of engineering details
make uh
like make the night and day difference
and i wonder if those kind of have a
ripple effect over time
so that that too so that's that's sort
of taking the engineering perspective
that sometimes that quiet innovation at
the level of an individual engineer or
maybe at the small scale of a few
engineers can make all the difference
that scales because we're doing we're
working on computers that are
scaled across large groups
that one engineering decision can lead
to ripple effects yes it's interesting
to think about
yeah i mean engineering
there's also kind of a historical
it might be a bit random
because if you think of the history of
how especially deep learning and neural
networks took off feels like
a bit random because gpus happened to be
there at the right time for a different
purpose which was to play video games so
even the engineering that goes into the
hardware um and it might have a time
like the time frame might be very
different i mean these the gpus were
evolved throughout many years where we
didn't even were looking at that right
so even at that level right that
revolution so to speak um
the ripples are like like
we'll see when they stop right but in
terms of thinking of why is this
happening right there's there's i think
that when i try to categorize it in sort
of
things that might not be so obvious i
mean clearly there's a hardware
revolution we are
surfing thanks to that um data centers
as well i mean data centers
are where like i mean at google for
instance obviously they're serving
google but there's also now thanks to
that and to have built such amazing data
centers we can train these models um
software is an important one i think
if i look at the state of how i had to
implement things to implement my ideas
how i discarded ideas because they were
too hard to implement yeah clearly the
ch the times have changed and thankfully
we are in a much better software
position as well
and then
i mean obviously there's research that
happens at scale and more people enter
the field that's great to see but it's
almost enabled by these other things and
last but not least is also data right
curating data sets labeling data sets
these benchmarks we think about maybe
we'll we'll want to have all the
benchmarks in one system but it's still
very valuable that someone put the
thought and time and the vision to build
certain benchmarks we've we've seen
progress thanks to but
we're gonna repurpose the benchmarks
that's the beauty of atari
is like
we solved it in a way but
we use it in gato it was critical and
i'm sure it's there's there's still a
lot more to do thanks to that amazing
benchmark that someone took the time to
put even though at the time maybe
oh you have to think what's the next
you know iteration of architectures
that's what maybe the field recognizes
but we need to that's another thing we
need to balance in terms of humans
behind we need to recognize all these
aspects because they're all critical and
we tend to
yeah we tend to think of the genius the
scientists and so on but i'm i'm glad
you're i know you have a strong
engineering background so but also i'm a
day i'm a lover of data and it's a
pushback on the engineering comment
ultimately could be the the creatives of
benchmarks who have the most impact
andre capazi who you mentioned has
recently been talking a lot of trash
about imagenet which he has the right to
do because of how critical he is about
image how essentially he is to the
development and the success of deep
learning around
uh image net and you're saying that
that's actually that benchmark is
holding back the field
because i mean especially in his context
on tesla autopilot that's looking at
real world behavior of a system
it's
you you there's something fundamentally
missing about imagenet that doesn't
capture the real worldness of things
that we need to have the datasets
benchmarks that
have the impressive unpredictability the
edge cases the whatever the heck it is
that makes the real world so com so
difficult to operate in we need to have
benchmarks with that so
but
just to think about the impact of
imagenet as a benchmark
and
that really puts a lot of emphasis on
the importance of a benchmark both sort
of internally a deep mind and as a
community so
one is coming in from within like
how do i create a benchmark for me to
mark and make progress and how do i make
a benchmark for the community to mark
and uh push
progress
you